sont retrouvés manuel chose notre envoyé
spécial à la frontière ukraino polonaise
vous vous trouvez depuis deux semaines
sur cette frontière et on voit beaucoup
des ong et de bénévoles étrangers
appuyer l'effort humanitaire sur place
comme vous voyez derrière moi et en fait
les gens continuent d'arriver ici je me
trouve devant la garde chez michel tout
près de la frontière à une dizaine de km
seulement et donc ceci est un point où
il ya des centaines de personnes qui
circulent chaque jour à l'heure
aujourd'hui c'est relativement calme
toute chose considéré mais tous toutes
ces personnes ont besoin d'être orienté
elles ont des besoins également
logistique et pour cela il ya beaucoup d
ong des ong polonaise incite les
autorités polonaises mais aussi beaucoup
des ong d'omg internationale américaine
irlandaise chinoise indienne est
également français je vous propose je
propose d'ailleurs d'écouter un des
bénévoles que j'ai rencontrés hier
encore de medica au cantou proche de
medica écoutons leurs motivations pour
venir ici
alors nous sommes venus nous sommes
présents sur place depuis environ 14 du
jour donc une première équipe
d'évaluation s'est présentée sur les
lieux pour quantifier positionner des
moyens ensuite donc nous sommes nous
arrivés et nous avons
mais en place ce camp avec ce poste
médical avancé au milieu d'eux d'autres
structures qui étaient déjà présentes
sur place en fait c'est une initiative
personnelle on a décidé de venir ici en
fait on est sapeur pompier en région
d'île de france et dès le début du
conflit on voulait faire quelque chose
parce que nos convictions s'arrête pas
aux frontières de la france donc on a
fait une collecte à la caserne de
pompiers de vous mon travail et le but
c'était de prendre un camion pour les
déposer ici ça se on a eu quelques
problèmes pour avoir un camion et bâle
plan b c'était de déposer la collecte
aux réfugiés chrétiens qui arrivait en
france c'est ce qu'on a fait et puis bah
ensuite on a pris un vol pour venir ici
on est quelques jours jusqu'à mardi on
va rester jusqu'à mardi pour aider les
associations humanitaires
pour le moment emmanuel la population
reste totalement solidaire
oui tout à fait d'autant qu'elle qu'elle
voit bien que cette aide elle vient de
l'étranger mais le maire de varsovie a
d'ailleurs tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
varsovie où se trouve 10 % de ceux de
ses plus de 1,5 million de réfugiés
venus d'ukraine le maire de varsovie qui
en appelle à l'aide de la communauté
internationale car si la pologne arrive
pour le moment tant bien que mal à
continuer d'accueillir ces structures
sont évidemment débordé alors le
gouvernement polonais a débloqué une
enveloppe de 1,6 milliard d'euros pour
tenter de gérer cette arrivée en masse
de tous ces réfugiés ukrainien mais
l'interrogation est la suivante cette
aide c'est une aide d'urgence et
beaucoup se posent la question qu'est-ce
que de ce qui va se passer dans quelques
semaines dans quelques mois quand les
gens qui jusqu'à présent ont été
solidaires auront toujours
d'aider des invités qu'ils ont bien
voulu accepter pour quelques semaines
mais la question se pose de savoir où
ira ou ira cet élan solidarité qu'elle
sera cet élan dans quelques semaines
dans quelques mois merci beaucoup
emmanuel chose merci à vous